just a barren wasteland right oh my gosh
yeah I kind of recognize this spot no
maybe I don't
[Applause]
hello everyone welcome back to potato
Moe the show where we take the best
looking games we know and turn them into
mush and as you can clearly see we're
playing one of the best looking games
out there The Witcher 3 it's been
requested I don't even know how many
times but it's one of the most popular
ones that you guys have asked for so
thanks to everyone that suggested it in
the comments now alongside me today is
the Jake Decker
also known as The Witcher expert in The
Witcher expert yeah so you have played a
good amount of this game and you kind of
know where everything is and most
importantly how beautiful the game is
correct it is gorgeous it is absolutely
is one of the most beautiful games I've
ever played
right so what we're gonna try to do here
instead of you know trying to show off
how beautiful it is we're just gonna go
in the complete opposite direction is
there a good Vista that we can go to
that will be a good comparison yeah hold
on let me take a look at the map here
right here yeah that's nice very perfect
all right so what we're gonna do is if
you want to go into the menus real quick
we're just gonna go into the options and
turn as much as we can down in the game
so we'll put everything on low I say
keep the resolution yeah now zoom and
it's actually it looks this looks pretty
decent
yeah like the foliage is nice and from
from a distance it doesn't seem that bad
but we can always go lower so thanks to
a mod called the ultimate graphics
options it gives us way more control
over what we can adjust here so ultra-
one is ultra but we're gonna go we're
gonna go to eight oh my god oh my gosh
oh all right so why is it purple so it's
just his undershirt right um so this
changes things quite
bitte oh my god I'm not exactly sure
what the myth does but you can see that
a lot of it's still like a lot of the
physics seem to be pretty intact
yeah I'm just everything is just giant
squares now let's let's call Roche and
let's go let's go somewhere looking as
sprightly as ever oh my gosh get on
little leap on there his head look at
his hair though his hair is gorgeous
this is like some post minecraft
apocalyptic world here hello merchant
wait why are they all red
I don't know I'm happy his bowl cut is
still they can kind of see you could
kind of start seeing the skulls
underneath yes they're starting to come
through but these are fine look at this
yeah the us fine all the graphics seem
to be just the in-game like rendered
stuff oh by some grant cards because
you're gonna want these later oh here's
that here's vesemir oh oh look what he
looks away or no maybe 20 blinks yeah
when he blinks nevermind his like eyes
go black for a second all right well
this is nice and all but I feel like we
can do a little bit more with this oh my
gosh so let's go back into that I don't
know exactly what these do specifically
this one is got rain shadows you know an
altar is a tea but I'm not sure if up is
more I think I think the hair will be
fixed when we go back in let's just
bring you this the resolution down to
like 720 at the very least keep it 16 by
9 okay and off we go oh my god so the
world you once knew as The Witcher 3 is
now probably just this like I think we
should go back to those uh those tree
areas or this forest because I don't
think there are any more trees anymore
you know what I think you're right oh
wait they're there they just take a
while to pop in is all just a barren
wasteland right oh my gosh yeah I kind
of recognize this spot no maybe I don't
wow how
look at that what is it some wolves down
there you're gonna be hiding in the
trees
yeah they can see if you can see them I
think what I what I will request of you
is I want to see but because as far as I
know about the which I don't really know
a lot about the world but I do know
about the romance no yeah okay I would
like to see us acquire maybe a lady of
the evening only good things will come
out of this joy only good things all
right are these ladies for acquiring I
like their I like their wardrobe colors
sorry it's very solid it's bringing out
the 80s like neon teals and reds and
Pink's oh my god I know where there's
another one that I know for a fact he
can let me try her can we take a look at
her real quick oh let me go to the other
brothel okay
also don't worry about the fact that I
know where the brothel it was about two
things only yeah don't ask questions
don't leave comments don't have any
don't worry about it Nova grads I think
is a good spot to test this out cuz this
is like the most taxing area in terms of
like CPU and how this game runs and like
the most is going on and also in my
shadow my shadow that's your shadow yeah
wait I think what's around again no it's
I think it might been the building but
like the game is not rendering all of
them it's only rendering maybe like one
shadow like in front of over where you
are maybe Joey
take your pick oh man there's so many to
choose from
let's go with the one with the least
amount of clothing okay not that I think
that will matter eventually but so I
think it's wasn't even mercy or Suzie so
yeah Suzie you want you want to talk to
her first
okay let's just go straight in we're
gonna go straight for it I can see
through this facade lifts off her wig in
the middle oh my she doesn't find
anything wrong with the fact that her or
geralt face is a different color from
his skin okay we're probably not gonna
be able to show all of this but I mean
you can't see the nipple we can describe
it too
everyone she's missing a couple of
things mrs. Horton parts oh my god her
face it's like being painted for some
reason oh oh that's not a good one
oh he enjoys it it's so much weirder
without expression too like it's like I
can't really tell what's I mean there's
oh yeah pay up man all right Jennifer
how you been do you did you never get a
haircut since we I know if we get too
far away her hair disappears so awkward
it's wide
I like how every time it's a close-up
their hair just like flips as it's like
Trey oh so that looks pretty good still
has a little necklace
yeah he's rich oh this is so wrong this
is bad
abort abort all right I think we've had
enough sexy okay well we still need to
finish this one also his hair is blonde
yeah white all right back to
civilization thank God all right should
I skip through this dialogue yeah let's
skip through some of this well let's
let's admire his beard for a little bit
here a little patchy trouble shaving
today yeah yes so and look at his
eyebrows his hair is starting to kind of
look like a construction paper project
yeah I know are you just like cut off
strips of of like white paper and just
glue it on to the side and then you just
make layers of it oh my god for some
reason this area right here like right
now it looks especially like yeah yeah
it's like I have this weird hybrid
cel-shaded yeah look one thing that's
fun to do
oh alright oh you died from that it's
nice I'm just gonna go the other way are
we good okay we're still we're missing
some things still oh wait can we get
close-up of this face real quick
or maybe just plant yourself in front of
a wall oh my god this is this is that
like a weird halfway point if like
though if like the previous one was just
broken this is kind of like like his
hair seems pretty good yes hair is fine
and then everything else is maybe like
some sort of weird like n64 like just
muddy textures all around yeah it was is
that that person yeah he's like missing
part of his body weight good sir okay
okay so we got the square the square of
foliage back to the left a little bit oh
yeah look at that beautiful landscape
okay look at that
what are those buildings they look like
building completion well it's like
before except there's the draw distance
isn't as bad because last time like that
wouldn't show up yeah but now we just
have like a nice skyline of square trees
so I think this is a very good place to
stop I'd say so I think we've done
enough damage to this wonderful game
already wait go back
he just loses pants as you walked by oh
you have x-ray vision now is that what
it is I think so look at that
Oh pants well anyway if you guys will
have a game that you'd like to see
destroyed and stripped down and removed
of all of its graphical fidelity let us
know in the comments and hopefully we'll
be back next time thank you all for
watching thank you
snowboard down the mountain died I don't
know I stood up